¿Alguna vez has estado en clase, empiezas a
aburrirte un poco y entonces comienzas a soñar
despierto? Y de repente tu mano parece tomar vida
propia, y empiezas a dibujar algo en la esquina de
una de las páginas del libro de texto. Seguramente
dibujarás algo más bonito que esto, pero lo que
dibujé por aquí es lo que se conoce en matemáticas
como una curva. Así que, ¿qué es una curva?
Casi todo lo que dibujes en una hoja de papel,
cuando empiezas en un punto, haces algo y paras,
esto es una curva; si hago esto, estoy haciendo
una curva, casi todo lo que hagas. Entonces,
¿qué no es una curva? Si dibujamos un círculo,
¿dibujamos una curva? Sí, empezamos en un punto,
seguimos y paramos, lo que puedes darte cuenta
por aquí es que en todos estos casos no hemos
levantado la mano del papel, podemos empezar y
hacer todo el trazo, todas estas son curvas. Pero,
imagina que queremos hacer una carita y agregamos
los ojos, ¿qué hemos hecho? Primero hicimos esto
y ahora tenemos estos huecos, y podemos ver
que no podemos hacer esta primera parte del
dibujo y después hacer los ojos sin despegar la
mano del papel, así que déjame marcarlo: este
hueco que tenemos aquí también se le conoce
como discontinuidad, pero puedes llamarlo hueco.
Por lo tanto, si existe un hueco, entonces
no es una curva, no es una curva. Es decir,
si queremos construir una curva, entonces debe ser
lo que llamamos continua. Tal vez si hago esto y
los conecto con unas gafas, si los conecto de esta
forma, entonces lo que obtenemos sí es una curva,
pero si tenemos estos huecos entonces no es una
curva. Ahora, ¿qué tal si dibujamos una recta?
Si te pregunto si es una curva, ¿cuál sería
tu respuesta? Piensa en esa pregunta. En el
lenguaje cotidiano podemos decir que un camino
es recto o es curvo, pero en matemáticas fíjate
en lo que decimos: si empezamos en un cierto
lugar y vamos hacia otro y paramos, mientras
sepamos que no hay huecos en lo que dibujamos,
entonces será una curva. Entonces, ¿es una línea
recta una curva? Sí, lo es, a pesar de que, en un
lenguaje cotidiano, no le llamamos curva. Podemos
ver que en matemáticas algunas palabras tienen
significados diferentes a los que normalmente
tienen en el lenguaje cotidiano. Entonces,
si esto es una curva, una línea es una curva,
entonces piensa en lo siguiente: si dibujamos
una línea de esta forma y después de esta forma,
¿es una curva? Estoy dibujando los extremos muy
grandes pero podremos dibujarla así, entonces
¿esta es una curva?, ¿esta es una curva?, o tal
vez podemos dibujarla así, ¿esto es una curva?
Sí, lo es: empezamos en un lugar y no tenemos
huecos entre las líneas que dibujamos. Incluso,
podemos dibujar algo más grande, algo como esto:
una cometa; esta también es una curva. Es decir,
cuando se usa la palabra curva, algunas personas
piensan que el trazo debe de ser curvo y que nunca
podría ser una línea recta, de hecho, dicen que no
debes usar una regla; pero no es así, usa lo que
quieras pero asegúrate de que los elementos estén
conectados, o que sea un trazo continuo. Ahora que
sabemos qué es una curva, tal vez podemos jugar
con esta idea. Te mostraré esta pantalla donde
tenemos algunas curvas a la izquierda y otras a la
derecha. Puedes tomarte un minuto, pausar el video
y considerar si hay alguna diferencia entre estos
dos grupos, de ser así ¿cuál es esa diferencia?
Bueno, si lo pensamos bien puedes notar que en
todas estas curvas a la izquierda no se presenta
lo que llamamos un cruce. Por ejemplo, al dibujar
esta curva hacemos este trazo, vamos por aquí y
cruzamos la curva en este punto, y podemos ver
que esto no ocurre en ninguna de estas curvas.
Justo por acá puedes ver otro cruce. En esta otra,
¿dónde tenemos el cruce? Bueno, está justo aquí;
y por acá en esta otra curva también tenemos un
cruce. Ahora, en este otro lado, sin importar
dónde dibujamos o lo que dibujamos, no tenemos
cruces. Por lo tanto, debemos mencionar que
todas las curvas que no tienen cruces, es decir,
que no se cruzan, las llamaremos curvas simples,
no se cruzan a sí mismas; mientras que las curvas
que sí se cruzan a sí mismas, es decir, que tienen
cruces, las llamaremos curvas no simples. Tal vez
existe un nombre más formal para estas curvas,
pero esta idea debería funcionar. Ahora, ¿qué
pasa con estos dos últimos diagramas de por aquí?
Podemos observarlos y ver que para dibujarlos
no tuvimos que cruzar la curva; por ejemplo,
por acá hicimos este trazo, después bajamos y
llegamos hasta acá. Entonces, aunque usamos la
palabra cruce, tenemos una mejor forma de definir
lo mismo. ¿Qué es esto de las curvas no simples
que deberíamos de saber? Primero, observemos
las curvas simples. La idea es que cada vez que
elegimos un punto por aquí, por ejemplo, podemos
elegir un punto por aquí, o podemos elegir este
otro punto, si vemos dentro de esta selección
podemos ver que existen sólo dos líneas que
salen de ese punto; si elegimos este otro punto,
podemos ver que existen sólo dos líneas que salen
de este otro punto, incluso en un punto medio.
Cada vez que elegimos un punto en estas curvas
de la izquierda, tenemos sólo dos líneas que
salen de él. De hecho, podrías preguntarte:
¿la curva no se cruza a sí misma en cierta forma?
Porque empezamos por aquí, hacemos todo el trazo y
regresamos al mismo punto de partida. Y observa:
pasa en todos estos casos. Bueno, incluso cuando
pasa esto, se sigue llamando curva simple. Pero
si podemos dibujar un círculo dentro del cual
existan tres o más líneas que salen de ese punto,
entonces hablamos de una curva no simple. Espero
que entiendas esta diferencia. Si observamos este
punto que seleccionamos, ¿cuántas líneas salen de
él? Tenemos una, dos, tres, cuatro, por acá una,
dos, tres, cuatro; incluso aunque no sean cuatro,
pueden ser sólo tres, con eso es suficiente.
Por ejemplo, por acá, podemos ver que son tres:
con esto es suficiente para que la curva sea
no simple. Recuerdo que cuando estaba en la
escuela tenía una curva favorita que solía
dibujar en mis libros, mi curva es esta,
me encantaba dibujar lo que se conoce como una
espiral, y siempre es muy divertida de dibujar,
especialmente porque es un poco difícil mantener
la misma distancia entre los trazos. Y la razón
por la cual me encanta dibujarla es porque una
vez que acabamos de dibujar, podemos verla y
parece que está rotando, no sé por qué pasa esto
pero parece que está rotando cuando realmente no
lo hace. Ahora, la pregunta que te tengo es:
¿dibujamos una curva?, ¿esto es una curva?,
¿tenemos o no huecos?, además, si es una curva ¿es
simple o es no simple? Piensa en estas preguntas.